[Music]
get you a bestie like lala
anthony a friend who will casually on
the fly
re-pierce your ear if you ask her to it
was
a whirlwind yeah so on tuesday kim
kardashian took to instagram to share a
behind-the-scenes look at her new skims
campaign photo shoot
where she recruited all her gal pals to
join her for a little twerking
champagne drinking
kardashian khloe kardashian hair stylist
jen
atkin lala and more were all there for
the fun
which included la la just straight up
re-piercing kim's ear
okay do you want me to
yeah i think it's the angle piercing my
ear
oh
lala later reposted that clip to her
instagram page
writing quote if anyone needs their ears
pierced
come see me my work is nice quick and to
the point
just ask kim kardashian it was a lot of
fun
and it looks like the 39 year old tv
host has some takers
chloe slid into the comments writing i'm
next
i love that to be honest guys this whole
thing
is giving me a major parent trap
flashback
cue the ice and apples one
two three
anyways lala opened up to e.t about her
long-time friendship with kim
last year gushing about her work ethic
ahead of the one-year anniversary
campaign for skims
i'm just so proud of her like you know
she comes up with these concepts she
executes them so amazing
and then you see it go from an idea to
this
huge huge company and it's just like wow
i remember when we were just
talking about this you know but i just
love to support
the people i love and care about it my
friends and to see her do so many
amazing things is
incredible so when she called and said
you know i want to do the one year
anniversary campaign i want you to be a
part of it i was like say no more i'm
there i mean i show up you know for my
friends and like i said people i love
and care about
you